Super Dad Kanye West picks his kids up
for school
[Music]
look at the lights look at the lights in
the outside are they recorded on outside
to see the lights in a fire truck I
don't know how you're gonna top that it
all goes down on Hulu's the Kardashians
Kanye arrives at Kim's house to grab the
kids and shows off his version of
morning carpool Kanye is here to pick up
the kids to take him to school he loves
to do that did you tell Santa no
so of course in his very Kanye way he
comes in a full fire truck dad picked
you up in a fire truck
how cool he's just the most genuine
person and you know he might say things
that
might get misinterpreted and people
don't see the context behind it but I
always know his heart and no surprise
here the kids love it and did you tell
Santa no
Mom said it was who gets to ride in a
fire truck I and once the truck was off
for school the cuteness continued are
you gonna wear one shot okay that's
gonna be so good Kanye has a little
advice for all the dads out there even
if you can't Wrangle a fire truck for
your morning commute I think sometimes
people are kind of bashful to be super
dads everybody wants to be like a cool
dad and sometimes you just gotta like
wear the fire hat
yeah I mean
sometimes you gotta wear the Easter
bunny costume but even before pulling
off the big surprise yea's enthusiasm
was at level 10. let me show you what
I'm picking the kids up
tomorrow stop you are for real that's
amazing it's dried in it with like a
seatbelt and stuff yeah I mean yeah
there's a whole thing we this one right
here
totally I think when I'm picking the
kids up and a fire truck tomorrow that's
so cute and that right there is Kim and
Kanye's co-parenting Dynamic on full
display you'll recall Kim filed for
divorce in February 2021 and despite a
lot of drama that's publicly played out
they're committed to raising their four
little ones together no matter what
we're going through I always want my
kids to be around their dad as much as
possible and just to have their mornings
with Dad and get dropped off at school
this Echoes what Kim's Sister Chloe told
ET in 2019 this is a family that learns
by example my mom and my dad were like
that it took them years but my dad would
come over once a week for family dinners
and would play golf with my stepdad so
we come from a family where we believe
in that and you share children with
people and that's how it should be and
while Kim and Kanye continue to
co-parent this game's founder has been
enjoying her new relationship with Pete
Davidson and it seems like they're the
real deal what's your favorite thing
about him
um he's just super genuine yeah and it's
just really fun to just
hang out and do nothing and
watch TV and just do nothing
that's my favorite thing what about the
goal is finding someone to do nothing
with it's the best since first being
linked romantically in October after
appearing together on SNL
and the way you are now Are You Gonna
Kiss Me Or Not I sure am Jasmine
the couple has been spotted all over
together they even made their red carpet
debut earlier this month at the White
House Correspondents dinner and also
attended the Met Gala
and in April A source told ET that their
romance is Rock Solid Kim is head over
heels for Pete they are in a great place
in their relationship and she is so
happy her family loves him too I love
that he's kind and really really
thoughtful he's the most thoughtful
person and I love yeah and I love the
chemistry that Kim and him have together
it's really sweet I thought you said the
chemistry it's like okay chemistry
foreign